let me ask you your own psychology sure
you're going after
some of the richest some of the most
powerful people in the world do do you
worry about your own Financial legal and
psychological well-being
uh yes
yeah I do I mean I'm not totally
oblivious to the precariousness
of like any kind of Journalism like this
obviously there's risks I've always
believed
there's a quote and I'm going to butcher
it but I hope you guys understand the
spirit of it
um
you know news is when you print
something someone else doesn't want you
to print everything else is public
relations
I really believe to do meaningful
journalism
you have to go after people like it's
not inherently a safe profession I mean
if you're going to do important work you
have to have risk tolerances and I think
everyone has a line of what that risk
tolerance is
and it's different for everyone I don't
think I could do what Edward Snowden did
I think that would be my bright red line
is going against my own government
it's such a in my opinion I really see
him as a hero like it's such a selfless
Act of self-destruction you know that
the the party you're going after has all
the power and will crush you
and you do it anyway out of the like the
true I don't know platonic ideal of
Journalism I think that's beautiful I
don't think I could do that I think I
need some ability to live and subsist in
the society that I am in
and I think my bright red line would be
like if I'm forced to flee the country
for my work I think I'd finally have to
say no but for as journalists go I'm
pretty risk I take risk pretty well
um I especially like think risk is
important to take when you're young and
when you can do that I think when I have
I mean I'm married so when I have a
family I think I will probably dial this
risk thing down just
being honest I mean I think you kind of
have to
um but right now I mean I'm kind of like
running on all cylinders I'm willing to
take on quite a quite a range of people
but um well you speak a lot about it
wolf pack of one or small yeah wolf pack
as opposed to having like a New York
Times behind you or a huge organizations
with lawyers with a team with a history
with these people are less courageous
this is the this is the dirty truth the
bigger the organization the more
conservative a lot of them are it's true
that sometimes they like and this is not
to bash big organizations I'm just
saying this is an observation of someone
who's talked to a lot of people and
especially in the world of fraud a lot
of them are scared to engage
in fraud that is obvious but hasn't been
litigated yet this is why you'll never
see documentaries about ongoing fraud on
Netflix it's too much of a liability
they'll Sue Netflix to hell and they
know that if they win Netflix has the
money to pay it so corporations like the
New York Times you know a lot of these
some of them are very Cur like they're
as courageous as they can be but at the
bottom line if someone sues you to hell
and back and you have to pay up you will
disappear and you're relying on
liability insurance which you're already
paying out the ask for to try to cover
you if you get sued but if you get sued
even if you win that liability insurance
now goes up in price the next year and
if you're the New York Times it goes up
by a lot so I mean
um I think there's work that independent
journalists can do uniquely that
they can actually take like in some ways
more risk than a giant institution which
has a lot more in my sense to lose even
though it would appear like they have
more in terms of Defense too but you get
uh you can be bullied legally yeah do
you get afraid of that sure I mean
I just uh
all these things are things you have to
be aware of and then forget to do your
job like you have to be you know it's
like it's like being like a snowboarder
and it's like do you realize you could
hit your head and it's like yeah of
course but in order to go do the like
the flip or whatever you have to just
accept the risk
mitigate the risk as much as possible
and move on so we have
um we have like insurance we keep like a
pool of funds for that kind of thing
like I'm very conservative with how I I
spend my money basically all on
production and like trying to make my
life as secure as I can and then I just
do the work that I you know I I want to
do because
so 99 of your fund goes into the in the
studio into the studio and then into
into that
elaborate space of yours yeah of course
um
how many kittens have to die to
manufacture that studio but anyway
that's that's my investigation for later
um
what what keeps you mentally strong
through all of this what's your source
of mental like strength of your
psychological strength through this
uh I think there was a time when I was
getting a lot of cease and desists some
people were like actually like like
saying like they're gonna show up to my
house all that kind of stuff I don't
think I was that um I think I was pretty
worried about that for a while my wife
was a huge short source of strength here
where she was like hey if you're not
comfortable with it you need to get out
of the game or you need to basically
like suck it up and like this is what it
is if you're gonna go after these people
you have to basically
um be mentally strong around this and
seeing her
have that realization helped me have the
same realization and I really deeply
admire and respect that about her and it
solved a lot of my concerns around that
it's just it just made me realize
every profession has risks it is what it
is you mitigate and then you move on
why do you think there's so few
journalists like you
you you're basically the embodiment at
least in the space you operate of what
grade journalism should be
why do you think there's very few like
you
okay
that's such an enormous compliment and
probably overstatement but
um
I first want to pay respect there are a
lot of great journalists and a lot of
them
are like I don't want to just kind of
take it and go yeah you know it's just
me there's so many great journalists
Matt Levine Kelsey Piper
um you know you've got Anonymous
journalists like Dirty Bubble you've got
citizen journalist like Tiffany Fong but
yeah but
I think if you're going to be in the
space in the long term you do need to
accept certain risks and I think in the
long term it's like
I don't know how easy it is to play that
game for a long period of time because
you make
to do great journalism you don't get
paid a lot compared to what you could
get paid if you did press pieces or
anything like that
you take a lot of risks legally you take
physical risks you take
it's just like if you care about money
it's not the profession
and I feel like
a lot of people when they get notoriety
they move to like well I can just
maximize the money security side of
things and I think it takes out a lot of
would-be great journalists
and also so first of all comfort of a
physical and mental well-being yes and
also being invited to parties with
powerful people uh you um
you make enemies rich and Powerful
enemies doing this
yes but that's why it makes it
that's why it's admirable I mean you
know uh it's it's an interesting case
study that you've been doing it as long
as you have
and I hope you keep doing it but it's
just interesting that it's rare
I'll say
I want to make a call like I think
societies can create
better journalists and worse journalists
insofar as they support the journalists
who are doing great work and I want to
call out Edward Snowden specifically
because what we have done to him is such
a travesty and the only lesson you can
learn if you're a logical human being is
that you should never whistle blow on
the United States Government after
looking at what they did to Snowden so
as a society
we can put pressure on lawmakers to make
it easier for people to do the great
work
by not punishing the people who do great
work if that makes sense and de-risking
it for them because we shouldn't expect
journalists to be martyrs to do great
work right to do important work and part
of that comes from protecting
whistleblowers there's like very common
sense things I love like it's great to
heroicize you know people like Edward
Stone and stuff like that but we
shouldn't expect them to be heroes to do
that work